hallo leute heute beantworten wir wieder
eine frage von euch und zwar heute von
unserer zuschauerin martha vater
schreibt hallo liebe kari und die
marianische bin von eurem videos auf
youtube sehr gespannt und gucke sie mir
gerne an dankeschön marta mir ist
aufgefallen dass ich einen konkreten
fall der deutschen sprache nicht
verstehe und zwar verwechsle ich sehr
oft die wörter ab und seit merke einfach
den unterschied nicht zwischen ab montag
und seit montag meine muttersprache ist
polnisch und wir haben nur ein wort für
diese aussage
ich kann das gut nachvollziehen
eigentlich ist diese regel für den
unterschied zwischen ab und seid sehr
einfach aber im englischen verwechsle
ich auch ganz oft zins und vor und ich
weiß eigentlich die regel und trotzdem
verwechsle ich es deswegen machen wir
heute mal ein video über den unterschied
von ab und seit und zeigen euch auch
einige beispiele dazu los geht's der
unterschied zwischen ab und seit ist
eigentlich ganz einfach
seit benutzt man immer für zeiträume die
in der vergangenheit angefangen haben
und bis heute andauern
ich bin seit zehn jahren verheiratet
das heißt vor zehn jahren habe ich
geheiratet und ich bin immer noch
verheiratet
ab hingegen benutzt man für zeiträume
die in der zukunft starten
zb ab morgen gehe ich jeden tag joggen
herr yannis hast du lust später zum
fußballgucken zu kommen
seit wann guckst du denn fussball
seit immer in dieser szene habt ihr zwei
mal seit gehört und beides mal
beschreibt seit einen zeitraum der in
der vergangenheit angefangen hat janosch
fragt mich seit wann guckst du denn
fussball
diese frage ist natürlich etwas
rhetorisch gemeint denn janisch erwartet
nicht wirklich dass ich ihm als antwort
einen konkreten zeitpunkt nennen
viel mehr wundert er sich so seit wann
guckst du denn fußball aber dieses
beispiel zeigt seit ist etwas was in der
vergangenheit anfängt also seit wann das
impliziert irgendwann habe ich
angefangen fußball zu gucken und das
mache ich bis heute
und ich antworte dann etwas
umgangssprachlich seid immer seid immer
ist natürlich kein vollständiger satz
aber in der umgangssprache hört man das
tatsächlich öfters ich kann also einfach
sagen seid immer guckt fußball seit wann
guckst du dein fußball seit immer okay
ich komme vorbei ab wann geht's los
also das spiel geht um 6 los aber du
kannst gerne schon ab fünf kommen
ok super dann bis später im zweiten teil
des gespräches benutzt janisch das ab
erfragt ab wann geht es denn los hier
beschreibt er also einen zeitraum der in
der zukunft anfängt ab wann geht es los
ich antworte dann das spiel geht um 6
uhr los aber du kannst gerne schon ab 5
uhr kommen und hier seht ihr auch diesen
unterschied zwischen um und ab um
beschreibt einen ganz konkreten
zeitpunkt es geht um 6 uhr los ab
hingegen beschreibt einen zeitraum wenn
ich sage es geht ab 5 uhr los heißt das
du kannst um 5 uhr kommen oder in
irgendeiner zeit nach 5 uhr also ab 5
uhr in der zukunft wenn ihr solche
grammatik fragen oder auch andere
fragen zur deutschen sprache mal mit
einer deutschlehrerin oder einem
deutschlehrer ganz direkt besprechen und
üben möchtet dann können wir euch
übrigens eishockey empfehlen
hockey ist der sponsor unseres heutigen
videos und es ist eine plattform auf der
man deutsch tutorinnen und tutoren
finden kann und dort private klassen
buchen kann
es gibt dort ganz verschiedene angebote
und auch ganz unterschiedliche preise
guckt euch das mal an auf der seite und
es ist auch hilfreich wenn man noch mal
einen partner hat mit dem man erst
deutsch sprechen üben kann und auch
vielleicht so ein bisschen den eigenen
lernprozess strukturieren kann wenn ihr
das jetzt mal ausprobieren möchte dann
geht auf goal.com / german und dann
bekommt ihr nach eurer ersten stunde
einen hockey kredit in höhe von zehn
dollar probiert es mal aus wir freuen
uns gleich die letzten fünf minuten 38
das war's deutschland ist raus aus der
em ab sofort gucke ich kein fußball mehr
seit wann bist du so eine drama queen
janisch selber drama queen in der
letzten szene seht ihr noch mal beide
wörter im direkten vergleich janisch ist
wütend und sagt ab sofort gucke ich
keinen fußball mehr
das heißt ab sofort das ist ein zeitraum
der jetzt sofort startet und in die
zukunft geht und ich mache mich dann ein
bisschen lustig darüber dass janisch so
emotional reagiert und sage seit wann
bist du denn so eine drama queen also
das seit ist hier wieder in der
vergangenheit gedacht aber bis heute
gilt jetzt könnt ihr diese frage mal
selber üben dann benutzt man ab wann
benutzt man seit wir haben wieder einige
interaktive übungen für euch vorbereitet
und in diesen übungen könnt ihr setzte
mit ab und seit in dieser woche üben
und wenn ihr weitere fragen habt und
schreibt uns mal einen kommentar wir
beantworten gerne eure fragen zur
deutschen grammatik zum den deutschen
vokabeln
alle fragen sind willkommen schreibt uns
einen kommentar und wir freuen uns wenn
wir uns auch nächste woche hier
wiedersehen tschüs und bis zum nächsten
mal kein fußball gucke ich gucke kein
schuss weil mir meine spieler